[Musique]
ça fait plaisir de reprendre une
activité culturelle concrète avec des
projections de films des rencontres de
la chaleur humaine avec les affaires
après la période que guide
et puis en plus de voir que cette 74ème
édition a vu là un record puisque vingt
films ont été soutenus par la région ile
de france c'est de rencontrer des
professionnels du secteur d'affiner des
dispositifs existants d'en prévoir
d'autres parce que valérie pécresse
avait un programme à un programme
extrêmement ambitieux pour cette
nouvelle mandature donc la voyons vient
de rencontrer à la filière des
scénaristes avant l'été avec l'acide
[Musique]
d'anticiper même sur les prochaines
semaines parce que le cinéma est un
secteur qui ne se portent pas si bien
que ça qui a besoin d'une ambition sans
cesse renouvelée et je ne trouve pas
qu'actuellement et apporte cette
ambition je n'ai pas eu de discours fort
donc c'est à la région de soutenir le
cinéma mais au delà du soutien d'avoir
une vraie ambition est de lui permettre
une meilleure rayonnance
[Musique]
un festival de cannes réussit c'est un
festival justement on a beaucoup de
films sélectionnés ce qui prouve que bas
des gens on a travaillé qu'on n'a pas
abandonné qu'on a soutenu du milieu et
qu'on a soutenu concrètement que du coup
ça a permis de l'emploi ça permis de la
rayonnant c'est ça leur permet surtout
d'être vu dans le plus beau festival du
mandat